qu'ils seraient attentifs merci monsieur
le ministre la parole étant monsieur
julien aubert
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre l'intérieur
une loi du 24 juin 2015 adopté de
manière consensuelle par le parlement a
cherché à rénover la protection de la
vie privée et notamment du domicile en
étant dans le délai initial de 48 heures
permettant aux forces de police de
constater un flagrant délit de squats
malgré cette avancée législatif le
sentiment d'injustice pour les
propriétaires lésés n'a pas diminué
en effet le nombre de squat de logement
se multiplient et dans certains de nos
quartiers un véritable système mafieux
d'occupation de logement s'est mis en
place qui rend la vie impossible pour
les riverains c'est le cas dans ma
circonscription et tout particulièrement
à pertuis à la résidence andré jaubert
qui recense une douzaine de logements
illégalement occupés par des squatteurs
de multiples troubles à l'ordre public
ont été constatés c'est le far west
les riverains sont exaspérés et n'osent
plus sortir ils subissent un trafic de
stupéfiants sans doute des lecteurs de
l'appel de marseille des portes de all
fracturé les tapages nocturnes et autres
incivilités commises dans l'illégalité
la plus totale
le 11 décembre dernier voilà même que
six véhicules ont été volontairement
incendiée sur le parking de la résidence
le maire de pertuis a d'ailleurs écrit
au premier ministre
malgré l'intervention des forces de
police et des procédures judiciaires en
cours
les squatteurs continue d'occuper
illégalement des logements en exploitant
la faiblesse de notre arsenal juridique
la justice sociale c'est de protéger les
honnêtes citoyens propriétaires aux
riverains la justice tout court s'est
brisé les reins des petits réseaux de
squatters se croient au dessus des lois
et qui rejoue tous les dimanches games
of new york
j'avais déposé le 20 mai 2015 une
proposition de loi visant à sanctionner
plus durement les squats en créant le
délit d' occupation sans droit ni titre
d'un immeuble
j'avais notamment proposé de rendre
obligatoire le recours à la force
publique
lorsque six noms de justice ordonne
l'expulsion
monsieur le ministre en agression est
double quelles mesures allez vous
prendre à pertuis et soutiendrez-vous
d'une nouvelle avancée législative pour
mieux protéger la propriété privée la
tranquillité publique
monsieur le ministre ne laissez pas les
squatteurs squatter votre pouvoir de
décision la parole est à monsieur le
ministre intérieur bruno le roux
oui monsieur le député julien aubert il
n'est pas question à pertuis pas plus
qu'ailleurs de laisser ceux qui sont
dans l'illégalité notamment dans les
occupations de locaux privés pouvoir
continuer à le faire je voudrais rendre
hommage
pertuis aux 55 gendarmes de la compagnie
du groupe d'intervention du psig qui
mène une politique résolue contre toutes
les formes de délinquance et celle ci
est une forme de délinquance
elle ne peut se résoudre sans le
concours tous les acteurs locaux et je
pense en particulier aux élus locaux et
aux bailleurs sociaux dont le cheveu
souligner la parfaite entente et la
façon dont nous pouvons travailler
ensemble
aujourd'hui je le réaffirme devant vous
nous avons les moyens aujourd'hui de
faire en sorte de faire cesser ces
squats
même si les décisions quelques fois mais
c'est le respect du droit peuvent
prendre trop de temps
je veux bien vous l'accordé je suis pour
ma part totalement ouverts dans les
textes qui pourront venir mais nous
sommes en fin de législature à regarder
les améliorations qui peuvent être
apportées mais je veux le dire ici sur
aucun point du territoire au pertuis pas
plus qu'ailleurs les forces de sécurité
n'ont la moindre des missions par
rapport à ce qui concerne la voie
publique ou les voies de fait commises
contre des particuliers
et là il s'agit de voies de fait
commises contre des particuliers
je remarque d'ailleurs que
l'identification de ceux qui font
aujourd'hui cela est notamment deux
bandes organisées
je n'irai pas plus loin pour ne pas
rentrer dans ce que sont les enquêtes
mais les enquêtes sont faites avec
minutie avec précision de telle façon
que ces réseaux sont connus et je puis
vous assurer que nous mettrons tout en
oeuvre pour qu'ils soient démantelées
merci monsieur